[Music]
right there
um
shoot
oh my god i always wanted to meet you
bro
hey bro do you know where your voodoo
area is
my brother
hello
hello state your emergency
yeah um there's a casualty here um i'm
trying to communicate with him he's not
responding
okay where's your location um i'm at a
communal place
is the person breathing um yeah yeah
he's not responsive
it's not
bad
was you guys as confused as he was well
guys the maliki opinion says that you
can play with your hands on your side
the point of this video is that if you
come across that you know that the
maliki is praying like that however
there is
prophet muhammad peace be upon him which
was narrated by abdullah ibn past that
says the prophet peace be upon him told
us to delay our
to break our fast immediately and also
that we place our right hand over our
left hand in prayer the chest of the
naval area which is the correct opinion
however this doesn't mean we disrespect
other people's opinion i hope you guys
enjoyed this video until next time
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
to continue to support the amazing work
salaam is doing
click the link and donate now